[Musique]
5 euros
beaucoup
[Musique]
la bagnole
vous êtes le boss des bosses pas faux la
désinvolture l'attitude les cuisses en
acier la plus jolie des fiancés
je suis en retard j'étais en train de
rassembler tôt butten de la terre pour
le propulser dans l'espace où il pourra
continuer ne rien faire hall mois
l'appel de ma vie c'est quoi ce délire
je m'appelle câble je viens chercher le
gosse quoi quel gosse tu pousses ou tu
crèves
les enfants nous rendent un peu meilleur
que ce qu'on est
il a besoin de toi ô alors toi tu es
plus futé que jordi nerfs je ne
laisserai pas câble qu est ce qu a marre
et j'y arriverai pas seul bien
qu'informé un groupe de la mort qui tue
et voilà notre groupe sera progressif
paritaire est connue sous le nom de
[Musique]
ex farce ça sent le réchauffé c'est moi
excellente remarque est maintenant
musique
un peu
walter
en béton
hot mois d'août ils ont bien chauffé le
ralenti la justice c'est pas toujours
propre
et si tu veux te battre pour le bien
parfois trop salir les doigts
le sign on pour hommes est à cette
génération ce que la coupe mulet était
aux années 80 c'est là que je m'en veux
d'avoir arrêté les études on va
satisfaire les attentes mais genre grade
plus de raison de faire un trois en or
est temps d'essayer bon s'arrête aux
deux essais du riz
[Musique]